>> Um, I know there's a broad question being
asked what do I think can be done this year,
and why there are many, many choices - I decided
to talk about Malaria. The reason I talk about
Malaria is that there are uh, a million children
die every year in Africa, over there. We have
all the tools that are necessary to prevent
those deaths. In addition there is an enormous
economic toll to Malaria and if we can prevent
this disease and to eliminate the mortality
that the child has, then we make a huge difference.
All it takes is a united effort in countries
by people who have the where-with-all and
the capabilities to launch programs on a very
aggressive footing to scale up the war against
Malaria. And such a coalition has come together
on the road back malaria under a strong task
force that is designed to create these national
plans or help countries prepare national plans,
coordinate them into a regional plan and go
on an aggressive time table of implementation.
I believe the time is right this year - we
should have universal access to bed nets,
we should have universal access to the next
generation drugs, we should have universal
access to indoor spraying. And if we are able
to do that, then I believe we can eliminate
all Malaria deaths within the next 3 to 5
years. That would be the one thing I would
think we should work on this year - hope you
agree - would love to hear your comments.